[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est à tous particuliers qu'on vous
propose d'aller voir à tous les
chroniqueurs sont magnifiques on va
parler bien sûr de péplum puisque
jonathan lambert et pascal de jonathan
lambert qui m'a dit je lui ai eus au
téléphone ce week end
il m'a dit quoi qu'il arrive je vais
arrêter l'antenne de débite je ne sais
pas par quels moyens
mais à un moment je vais arrêter la
diffusion de toutes parts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez-y alors qu'elle semblait beau big
boy et en personnel qui va se passer là
ça reste entre nous un bijou pas mal ces
partis cités la balle on y va on y va on
arrive à point en trois points gagne on
attend le perdant doit enlever le reste
le reste du peu que j'ai déjà oui oui ah
ben je vais mais tout nu à la ba oui si
je perds voisine attention c'est parti à
trois points oh la la la la la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'abord matador tu commences à avoir
froid
[Applaudissements]
présomptueux de la toge et celles aux
attentes a gagné une aura et nora se
promène dans la rue mais vous m'avez a
construit avec la petite danse tout ça
et nora allégi mais tu vois en place on
va voir ce que ça donne regardez soit
vous êtes à basso cambo mais comme ça
c'est tout là bas vous venez de la balle
vient de là et on va voir la technique
que gilbert des indécis tiens je me
balade
mais non patrick attendait donc en suis
dit que j'allais y sont même pas encore
vu le gars comme ça oui
[Applaudissements]
allons-y donc gilles verdez allons-y
donc et doha marche dans la rue alice
mais voilà et je danse avant qu'elles
arrivent et j'attire son attention
[Rires]
trois des nombreux jeunes urbains d'une
chose est sûre mais c'est sûr il ya dix
ans dans ce laisser aller bosser ça là
ça suffit
parce qu'il ya des autres s'il a toute
ses bijoux dont il a fait preuve à 21h
quand même volley ball du sable n'ont
cessé
[Applaudissements]
jonathan dufrasne visiter un petit peu
maciocia louis à toile pas sur la touche
il faut l'enlever monsieur non mais
[Applaudissements]
tu veux visiter la régie j'adorerais
voir gérez vous en mettra passion non
non il ne fait pas comme ça surtout
kevin
[Musique]
là
qu'est ce qui se voit ce monsieur s'est
échoué alors rentrer dans le bien dans
les régies la régissent et c'est de là
que le réalisateur appuyez sur les
boutons
oui voilà bonsoir ya plus de spectateurs